la menora c'était le seul instrument qui
donnait de la lumière dans le lieu saint
autrement tout était dans l'obscurité et
c'était l'image donc de la lumière de
dieu de la lumière de la torah qui est
clair que les hommes qui s'approche de
dieu elle représente toute l'histoire
d'israël vous avez ici le médaillon
central avec schémas israël et vous avez
ici sur la branche inférieur le texte de
sa carri 4 où il est question de la
menora d'or que le prophète voix il y a
sur les sept branches des lettres de feu
qui sont constitués et en hébreu il y a
cette mot dans ce verset qui dit non par
puissance ni par force mais pas mon
esprit dit l'éternel des armées et c'est
écrit sur la branche inférieur alors
vous avez ici des scènes de lin de
l'histoire d'israël et notamment ici là
la révolte des ghettos les ghetto de
varsovie
la vallée des ossements desséchés
desquels vous avez ensuite ici moïse et
aaron et ou four qui sont qui
soutiennent les mains de maurice fatigué
à côté vous avez sur la gauche david qui
tient la tête de voler at qu'il vient de
décapiter
regardez aussi sur la deuxième branche
vous avez il/elle avec le païen qui se
tient sur un pied pendant qu'on lui
enseigne toute la torah l'idée du
professeur
arrêt ou venu c'est que les sept
branches du chandelier est bien faisait
une flamme qui chacune faisait à
mouiller avait 17 mosou je me sers
chacune des sept branches du chandelier
donc ici la vue la ville de jérusalem
tels que ceux trouvés au début des
années 60 nous avons ici devant nous
regardez bien ces structures là c'est le
temple qui n'a jamais existé
comme vous le savez c'était une mosquée
alors le tant pis si on le voit très
bien c'est l'esplanade qui existent
encore sur laquelle sont construites
effectivement les deux mosquées le dôme
de la roche est situé à l'endroit où
était le sanctuaire et la mosquée
al-aqsa qu'ici au niveau de la structure
avec des tuiles rouges vous voyez là ça
c'est ce que joseph à lui s'appelle la
sto à royal nous avons une description
très précise de jérusalem nous est
donnée par l'historien juif flavius
josèphe et il nous décrit le temple avec
précision.mais donc ici c'est ce qu'on
appelait la sto à royal c'est à dire une
un ensemble de constructions qui servait
pour remiser les trésors du tente des
trésors du temple était conservé dans
cette partie là mais en dessous vous
avez le fameux portique de salomon notre
éducation dans l'évangile où jésus où se
tenait donc les les rabats qui
enseignait c'est là que jésus à l'âge de
12 ans se trouvait dans le temple il
interrogé les docteurs qui se trouvait à
cet endroit là est lui-même ensuite
quand il est devenu adulte il a enseigné
dans cet endroit là donc le portique de
salma est cité dans l'évangile le temple
avant sa reconstruction par hérode le
grand est est situé sur une colline
lorsque et rod est arrivé au pouvoir il
était à 1 mais ils avaient l'intention
d'acheter en quelque sorte la sympathie
de son peuple en reconstruisant le
temple a été son projet et son projet
est essentielle alors il a créé ce
qu'ils étaient
des merveilles du monde ancien le temple
les salles et ça ce serait nous disent
que c'est lui qui n'a pas vu le temps
que des rhodes dans toute sa splendeur a
jamais rien vu de beaux dans sa vie
alors il à araser la colline il en a
fait un plateau comme vous le voyez là
et pour éviter les éboulements il a calé
cette terrasse avec des murs gigantesque
alors de 4 côté vous avez donc ici les
murs de soutènement de la colle delà de
la terrasse dont le mur occidental et
qui est aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle
donc le comme si son talent ou encore ce
que les non juifs appellent le mur des
lamentations n'est pas vraiment un mur
des lamentations d'ailleurs
le parvis extérieur ici c'est un endroit
où tout le monde pouvait venir y compris
les non juifs selon ap le parvis des
non-juifs de partir parmi les goyim il
était entouré par des colonnades de
marbre blanc qui était un directement
importé d'italie et quand on a refait la
maquette ici le professeur evionnaz a
fait revenir d'italie le même type de
marne que c'est exactement et comme ce
que jésus a vu ce que vous voyez là
c'est la vue que jésus avait quand il
est venu depuis jéricho comme le jour
des rameaux il a il est arrivé au sommet
du mont des oliviers et c'est de là
qu'il a pleuré sur la ville en voyant
justement cette ville magnifique comme
nous voyons et senna voyons absolument
aujourd'hui c'est la vision que jésus a
eu alors les jours des grands
pèlerinages vous avez une place ici au
sud du temple et les foules se
rassemblent et là c'est là que pierre a
fait le discours le jour de la pentecôte
et la foule était rassemblée sur la
place ici pour entrer dans le temple
alors il y avait différentes me porte
pour entrer dans le temps pour pouvait
montrer par là certains pensent qu'il y
avait d'ailleurs un pont qui enjambe est
ici la vallée du cédron qui n'a pas été
reproduits sur la maquette parce que
finalement il ya des discussions à ce
sujet là vous avez aussi un escalier qui
a accès d'une passerelle
on a retrouvé le départ le point de
départ de cette arche qui permettait
d'accéder directement à la sto à royal
on entrer dans le temple par là en
venant de la vidéo hot on pouvait entrer
directement là on a retrouvé les deux vu
la rue est ouest j'étais au site du
temple et la rue nord sud puis longé la
partie ouest du temps et là il y avait
donc les endroits où les marchands de
pigeons les marchands de bestiaux
vendait à vos pèlerins les animaux dont
ils avaient besoin pour les sacrifices
et dans le temple on n'avait pas le
droit de l'utiliser une autre monnaie
que la monnaie du temps parce que dans
les autres monnaies il y avait des
effigies des représentations humaines ou
des représentations animales ce qui
était interdit par la torah et donc on
était obligé de changer la monnaie du
pays avec laquelle on arrivait en
monnaie du temps par conséquent il y
avait des changeurs c'était normal
c'était s'était pas c'est pas quelque
chose notre juge lequel jésus s'est
dressée c'est simplement le fait que les
l'échangeur qui étaient des employés des
grands prêtres prenez des commissions
qu'elle est de l'ordre de 200 250 % sur
les droits de change c'était un
véritable racket et le talent nous nous
raconte que quand khalife qui était un
des plus mauvais grand prêtre est arrivé
au pouvoir il a décuplé le prix d'une
paire du pigeon donc l'épaule ne pouvait
plus offrir de sacrifices et c'est là
que jésus avant va renverser les fameux
table des changeurs de monnaie
j'avais des portes qu'on a retrouvés
dans les fouilles archéologiques
aujourd'hui les portes du temple ce sont
des structures du temple qui reste et
qui permettait d'entrer sur le parvis
des gentils des païens ensuite on avait
le sanctuaire proprement dit entouré
dans ce cadre il à terre deux murs là et
vous avez deux coups qui sont séparés
par une muraille la première
koussa paix la cour des femmes il y
avait ici deux portes on a là ça c'est
la belle porte avec elle se trouvaient
le paralytique a été guérie par pierre
et jean et ensuite vous avez si une
porte qui était recouverte d'or c'est ce
qu'on appelle la porte de nicanor le
soleil se levait derrière le mont des
oliviers et le matin les premiers rayons
du soleil venait se refléter dans les
portes d'or les prêtres quand il voyait
ses reflets ouvrait les portes et on
offrait le sacrifice du matin c'était le
début de la journée
il y avait à l'entrée de ces deux sets
port de nicanor une inscription en trois
langues en hébreu en grec et en latin
qui avertissait que tout non juifs qui
franchirait cette limite seraient mises
à mort immédiatement son jugement même
si c'était un romain et vous vous
souvenez que on avait accusé paul
d'avoir fait rentrer dans cette partie
là titre qui était un non juif et c'est
comme ça que paul a été arrêté en
principe montrer que des gens qui
appartiennent au peuple d'israël et
notamment les femmes c'est la raison
pour laquelle on appelle cette cour-là
la cour des femmes alors il y avait de
chaque côté des espèces 2 d'entrepôts
que vous voyez là aux quatre coins de la
delacourt des femmes qui étaient des
endroits où on gardait les vêtements des
prêtres ont gardé tout ce qui était
nécessaire pour le culte du temps vous
avez ensuite un escalier en demi cercle
là-bas à 15 marche ces marches c'était
l'endroit où se tenait les coeurs des
les buts moment des grands pèlerinages
et ils chantaient les psaumes des
pèlerinages néo 15 somme à partir du
psaume 101 donc qu'ils étaient les
psaumes qui était chantée par les
pèlerins qui venaient en pèlerinage à
jérusalem est
les femmes ne pouvaient pas franchir
cette porte elle pouvait monter sur les
balcons qui sont sur les bâtiments à
l'extérieur et voir ce qui se passait
dans l'autre court et dans l'autre court
mais vous aviez
l'hôtel des sacrifices qui est semblable
à l'hôtel du monde balle clés tels
endroits où on offrait donc les
sacrifices les hommes entrés avec des
animaux consacré lesquels animaux
avaient été lavés d'abord préalablement
dans cette piscine là bas que vous avez
avec des dt toits rouges une puisse y a
cinq portiques la piscine de bethesda
c'est là qu'a été guéris donc le
paralytique dont nous parle l'évangile
de jean et qui a été donc l'endroit où
jésus a fait ce miracle assez
extraordinaire les animaux étaient lavés
dans la bbc à cet endroit là et il
entrer dans la ville par cette porte là
cette petite porte que vous voyez là
qu'on appelait la porte des brebis et la
porte des troupeaux parce que c'était
par la contrer les animaux pour les
sacrifices et ensuite ils étaient
sacrifiés sur l'autel sur l'autel des
sacrifices qui se trouve dans la coup
d'israël la deuxième course ça s'appelle
l'accord d'israël là tous les israélites
avec le droit d'entrée pour offrir des
sacrifices et puis après on a à l'inter
de la structure couverte on a le
sanctuaire proprement dit qui lui-même
été divisé en deux il y avait dans une
un rideau donc le vide l'homme qui
séparait le lieu saint du dieu tresses à
un vide sur lequel étaient tissés des
chérubins et à l'intérieur vous aviez le
lieux saints dans lequel il y avait les
trois objets qu'on a vu dans le
tabernacle c'est à dire au nord la table
des pins au sud la menora et au centre
l'hôtel des parfums l'hôtel des parfums
ou officiers à carry le père de jean
baptiste au moment où la télévision de
l'ange tel qu'on le voit dans l'évangile
de lui
ensuite il y avait le lieu très sain qui
était situé dans la deuxième partie de
ce sanctuaire qui y est il absolument
évident à l'époque du premier temple
y'avait large de l'alliance à l'époque
ce deuxième tome la large alliance il
avait disparu il ya simplement le rocher
l'emplacement sur lequel on peut voir
d'ailleurs encore l'enfant fracture
hésiter taille est exactement dimension
de l'arche laquelle large était déposée
à l'époque de salomon donc le grand
prêtre franchissait cette
série d'eau une fois par an pour le jour
de kippour avec le sang
vous fait expiatoire et à défaut de
faire d'explications sur le couvercle de
larges propitiatoire il le faisait sur
cet emplacement où étaient l'arche de
l'alliance autrefois alors la jurée
alliance en principe et les cacher
quelque part dans des tunnels qui sont
en dessous du temps
elle rapportera autant de la fin ce sera
un didier dessinée avant la venue du
messie serein tradition juive remarqué
aussi qu'il ya des espèces de piques sur
le toit du sanctuaire tout ça c'est de
l'or tout ce qui est doré était de l'or
les chapiteaux des colonnades aussi
était dehors et vous de l'eren n'avait
pas lésiné les pics en question étaient
là pour que les oiseaux ne viennent pas
souillé par leurs déjections le
sanctuaire donc voilà ça s'est poursuivi
concerne le temps
à la droite
j'avais une forteresse là avec 4 tours 5
tours même si la forteresse antonia elle
avait été construite par hérode le grand
en souvenir de son ami antoine le
triumvirat qui avait été vaincue on le
sait axium par octave mais
vraisemblablement sur la maquette est un
peu trop grande c'était la garnison de
la cohorte que garder jérusalem d'accord
thurman qu'il ya des jeunes alem et ça
servait aussi de prison
peut-être ça servait aussi de lieu de
jugement le tribunal ça on en discute le
problème est de savoir est ce que jésus
a été jugé dans l'entonnoir et le procès
civil de jésus devant pilate at-il vieux
devant d'antonia jusqu'ici c'était la
dalle thèse qui a été celle des dames de
sion dont le monastère est situé sur
l'emplacement de l'antonnière justement
l on vous trouvé les restes de lento dia
sous leur monastère ont effectué des
fouilles et là sera de lui notamment
pensent avoir découvert ce qu'on appelle
le litre strauss
gabbana en araméen c'est à dire le lieu
sur le caine pilote avait son tribunal
maintenant cette revue est contestée par
les israéliens le problème c'est de
savoir ou visitez le gouverneur romain
quand il venait à jérusalem parce que en
temps normal le gouverneur romain ne
résistait pas à jérusalem mais à césarée
sur la côte la capitale politique
n'était plus générale m à l'époque
romaine c'était cesare et le
gouvernement ne venait à jérusalem que
pour la fête de pâques parce que la fête
de pâques était par excellence une fête
messianique et les faux messi se
soulever à l'époque de pâques et à
chaque fête de pâques on était
pratiquement certain qu'il y aurait des
émeutes messianique c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles jésus a été
arrêté aussi sous l'accusation d'être un
agitateur politique il a été couronné en
il a été crucifié en tant que tel en
tant qu agitateur politique n'était pas
mais on l'accusé d'être un agitateur
productif et le gouverneur romain
d'occulter ses arrêts avec des renforts
et il venait jura l'ain pour toute la
semaine de pâques où les ide et il
réside études dans l'entonnoir une
caserne une prison pour un gouverneur
romain c'est pas très confortable du des
israéliens c'est que
il y avait un endroit qui était beaucoup
plus confortable pour le gouverneur au
mas était le palais d'hérode on verra
tout à l'heure l'idée était que le
gouverneur romain résider dans le palais
d'hérode et non pas dans l'entretien et
ce faisant le procès civil de jésus
n'aurait pas eu lieu dans l'enseignement
mais dont le palais d'hérode en tout cas
une chose est sûre c'est que c'est dans
cette forteresse là que paul a été
emprisonné quand il a été arrêté pour
avoir un terrain qu z avant de vouloir
faire entrer titre par la porte ici la
porte dorée et la foule s'était
rassemblée devant la force d'antonia
épaules avait fait son discours sur les
marches jusqu'au moment où il avait dû
que le seigneur envoyés vers les païens
et là il avait été interrompue
brutalement
jérusalem dans son ensemble
je nous alem et défendu de trois côtés
c'est à dire du côté est par le ravin du
céderont au sud vous avez une autre
vallée qu'est la vallée de la gn donc à
l'est à l'ouest et au sud vous avez une
défense naturelle des deux vallées se
rejoint d'ici dans cette partie sud donc
ça fait une défense naturelle le seul
endroit qu'elle n'est pas protégées
naturellement c'est le nord donc toutes
les attaques contre jeune j'allais me
viennent du nord
c'est donc le nord qu'il faut faire
certifier le plus et c'est la raison
pour laquelle à l'est au sud et à
l'ouest vous avez une seule muraille qui
défend la ville là vous avez une série
de trois rangées de murailles une
muraille qui est la muraille du temple
londonien et qui
rejoint ensuite la balle une structure
que vous voyez il ya des tours que vous
voyez là bas donc ça c'est la première
muraille la deuxième muraille elle par
delà l enveloppe donc ici tout le
quartier nord et elle rejoint le temple
antonia et puis à partir de 44 après
jésus-christ on a construit une
troisième muraille pour protéger le fait
que jérusalem c'était beaucoup
développée et vous avez un quartier que
c'est un instrument qui s'était
construit en dehors des murailles la
troisième muraille a été la première qui
a été conquise par les romains au nom du
siège de jérusalem elle n'était pas
véritablement achevé de toute manière
tant et si bien que les romains n'ont eu
aucun mal pour la prendre titus le
général romain a établi son camp sur le
mont des oliviers évidemment ça nous
permet d'avoir une vue panoramique des
opérations militaires qui se déroulent
dans le bas et quand il a installé son
camp il a effectué une patrouille pour
faire le tour des murs à john allen pour
examiner les points faibles de la ville
et continuent d'arriver
à la porte que vous voyez là bas
viennent portes de la iiième reich les
juges ont fait une sortie et ont essayé
de capturer il s'en est fallu d'un
cheveu que titus ne soient capturés ou
mise à mort il s'en est sorti grâce à sa
bravoure personnelle le sort de la
bataille de zanet mauvais peut-être
changer si tu savais été capturés ou
tués
cet endroit est l endroit le plus
vulnérable des défenses du jérusalem
parce que c'était l'endroit où se
rejoignent les trois muraille et c'est
une des raisons pour lesquelles c'était
l'endroit le plus fortifiée fortifiée
comment par 3 to monumentale que vous
avez là trois tours ont été construites
par hérode le grand père auquel il a
donné les noms de fat sahel son frère
qui avaient été tués au moment où il
avait pris le pouvoir
ipic us qui était un de ses amis et
surtout la plus élégante la plus
gracieuse de tout myriam sa très chère
épouse qu'il aimait tellement qu'il a
fait assassiner par amour par amour sur
la wii et aujourd'hui c'est à cet
endroit là que se trouve ce qu'on
appelle la tour de david
c'est tout de david n'a rien à voir avec
david du tout parce qu'à l'époque de la
vue toute cette région là était
absolument déserte ce sont les croisés
qui vont appeler cet endroit là la tour
de la ville parce qu'ils ont fait de cet
endroit qui existe encore aujourd'hui
mais il reste plus qu'une seule tour
qu'il a tourné face à elle ils ont fait
de cet endroit le palais des rois de
jérusalem les rois croisée de jérusalem
donc été les successeurs de david
habiter dans cet endroit là et au sud de
ses trois tours vous avez le palais
d'hérode qui commence est aujourd'hui le
jardin arménien et rohde avait construit
sa avec un luxe absolument inouïe avec
des piscines avec des plans d'eau et
s'étire à face était vraiment une
splendeur il ne se refuse rien et vous
voyez cet été c'était fortis était une
forteresse à l'intérieur de la
forteresse à l'intérieur de jérusalem et
en 70 lorsque je vous allez mettons b il
y avait deux structures qui résistait
encore c'était
le temple
est plus la forteresse ici la forteresse
intérieur le palais d'hérode ça ils ont
résisté encore un mois après la chute de
jérusalem
est donc selon les savants israélien
c'est là qu'au review le procès civil de
jésus
il tant que dans l'ancien
bien alors ici nous sommes au sud de la
ville avec ici la frontière entre la
vidéo haute et la ville basse
regardez le contraste dans la ville
haute vous avez des superbes villas là
vous avez des maisons beaucoup plus
fruste beaucoup plus simple ça c'est le
quartier populaire de jérusalem la ville
à vis de basse et là vous avez donc le
sud du palais d'hérode et le quartier
des grands prêtres les grands prêtres
habiter sur la colline où est ce qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui la colline de sion
donc ici les villas des grands prêtres
et notamment la première villa ici la
résidence du grand prêtre et c'est donc
là qu'a eu lieu le procès religieux de
jésus c'était la maison de cas est fait
maison de qualif et la maison de rayan
qu'était son beau père le grand prêtre
était le principal personnage de la
ville de jérusalem il était à la fois un
chef spirituel mais était aussi un chef
politique le pour éviter qu'ils ne
prennent trop de pouvoir les romains
avaient pris l'habitude de déposer le
grand prêtre tous les 4-5 ans à peu près
et de le remplacer par un autre et la
grande prêtrise tourner autour de cinq
familles sacerdotale donc les fiable des
fans les annales les quatre os
b atos est ce que les cinq familles qui
se partageaient la grande prêtrise ici à
jérusalem maintenant ce quartier si de
quartier absolument au sud issue c'est
ce qu'on dit joseph la vue s'appelle le
quartier et saignante les sélestadiens
donc avec un quartier à jérusalem
les étudiants de qumrân et vous avez eu
6,7 porte qu'on appelle la porte d es
sénia et c'est dans ce quartier là que
se trouve le cénacle là où jésus donc
après le dernier repas avec ses
disciples pourquoi parce que l'évangile
nous dit que jésus en voici les deux de
ses disciples région pour chercher un
endroit où il va célébrer la pâque avec
ses disciples et il dit ceci quand vous
entrerez dans la ville vous rencontrerez
un homme portant une cruche d'eau
bon ça c'est ça interpelle personnes
c'était le travail des femmes donc voir
un homme portant une couche d'eau cet
écueil racing ainsi une pas banal et
pourquoi ce brave homme se situe sa
corvée d'eau lui-même et faisait pas
faire ça par sa femme
parce qu'il en avait pas de femmes parce
qu'ils étaient esséniens les esséniens
se marier pas
il était le propriétaire de ce
caravansérail qui se trouve ici dans une
de ces maisons qui est sur la droite et
jésus donc appris le dernier repas dans
le quartier scénario c'est un des lieux
sur le plan d'authenticité est un des
dieux les mieux attester qu'ils soient
bons pourquoi justement appelle-t-on
cette porte porte des esséniens et bien
parce que les esséniens les pauvres ils
étaient tenus à des règles très strictes
et notamment le jour du shabbat le jour
de fête je n'ai pas de refaire le besoin
pourquoi parce que jérusalem était
considéré comme un camp et il est écrit
dans le livre du zéro nomme que pour
faire ses besoins il fallait sortir du
camp
par conséquent les conditionner à vail a
connu qu avec une seule solution c'était
de sortir à toute vitesse hors des
murailles de jérusalem pour aller se
soulager et par conséquent il habitait
tout près de la porte
pour pouvoir en cas de besoin
sortir le plus rapidement possible
les esséniens étaient des gens secteur
c'était des gens qui considéré qu' on ne
pouvait pas
on était prêts déterminés d'avancé salut
à la perdition on était soit très
déterminé à être fils de la lumière ou
être fils des ténèbres
et si vous étiez déterminée pour être
fils des ténèbres j'avais beau faire
vous étiez perdu quoi qu'il en soit
finalement les seuls qui était sauvée
c'est un des membres de la csc les
esséniens russell étaient les fils de la
lumière est là on est aux antipodes du
message de jésus jésus appelé les
pêcheurs les prostituées les publicains
les péages et les jeunes au vésuve il
les appelait à la repentance ça pourrait
nous signale c'était impensable
les pêcheurs il était pêcheur ils
étaient destinés à la perdition quoi
qu'ils fassent donc il servait à rien
d'essayer des affaires la repentance de
toute façon il serait perdu les essais
niasse et c'est un groupe assez complexe
5vous passé assez pluraliste n'y a pas
un seul type décédé à semble-t-il il ya
plusieurs types il y avait les
estimations de stricte obédience qui
effectivement ne se marier pas vous
aviez des excuses et des destins qui se
marier pour la reproduction justement je
réponds à votre question
et il sait c'est d'avoir des relations
avec leurs femmes dès que vous avez un
enfant et puis vous aviez des étudiants
qui vivent une vie normale qui se
mariait qui avaient des enfants comme
tout à chacun élever les trois les trois
les trois tendances
bon maintenant on m'a posé la question
où se trouve le golgotha alors sa grosse
question il ya peu de données qui nous
sont donnés dans l'évangile au sujet de
l'emplacement du désordre gotha
simplement il nous est dit que c'était
hors des murailles à l'époque de jésus
la troisième rail n'existait pas donc
c'était simplement au dehors de la
deuxième muraille et vous avez réussi
une carrière regardez bien là et selon
un général anglais qui s'appelle gordon
il a trouvé un tombeau de l'époque de
jésus et une falaise qui ressemble à un
crâne on sait que ça s'appelait golgotha
ça vient de l'hébreu google est que
signifie un crâne tout ce qu'on a trouvé
dans cet emplacement là est parfaitement
cohérent avec le donne évangéliques on
n'a pas de preuve absolue que c'est
l'endroit en question mais on n'a pas de
preuve non plus du contraire donc la
question reste ouverte mais rien
n'empêche que le golgotha soit situé à
cet endroit là sur cette carrière que la
rue qui est situé donc très près de la
muraille et vos avantages comme vous le
voyez ce qu'il y avait ici une voie
romaine qui allait des stones ouest les
romains aimé crucifié le relais condamné
dans des endroits très passants pour
impressionner un peu le public est donc
jésus aurait pu être que chercher à cet
endroit là maintenant il ya un autre
endroit qu'on donne aussi comme étant le
golgotha que juste à côté de la muraille
ce serait l'endroit du tombeau de jésus
désordre du vol gotha et du tombeau de
jésus ça c'est la tradition qui remonte
à hélène la mère de l'empereur
constantin à l'époque où j'ai nous alem
avait été une ville païenne elle avait
été transformée par l'aprue l'empereur
hadrien elle avait été changé de nom
s'appelait aelia capitolina et le temple
invité sur le temple avait été dressé
une statue de la drian sous la forme de
jupiter capitole à l'endroit où il se
trouve actuellement le saint sépulcre
avait été transformé en sanctuaire de la
déesse vénus et à cet endroit là
certains chrétiens se serait souvenu
certain que c'était l'endroit un endroit
du dota hélène oury creusé à cet endroit
là elle retrouvé donc et le tombeau et
le volta et même la vraie croix la vraie
croix que l'on montre encore dans le
saint sépulcre qui est sous une chasse
de verre pour une bonne et simple raison
c'est que inde et des exigences du
pèlerinage c'était qu'on a embrassé la
vraie croix
mais en embrassant la vraie croix les
pèlerins mort des deux dents
pour emmener un morceau on est dans le
pays des miracles mais quand même
pour vous un temps il risque et de
risquer de voir disparaître la vraie
croix alors on a mis sous une chasse de
verre maintenant et on embrasse
simplement la chasse de verre
quant à la découverte de la vraie croix
eusèbe de césarée de l'historien du
christianisme du
l'ancien et franchement sceptique
pour ce qui est de l'emplacement du
golgotha il est mitigé mais pour ce qui
est de la vraie croix il est vraiment
sceptique alors disons calais quelles
sont les chances d'authenticité des deux
lieux
le saint sépulcre traditionnel il a pour
lui d'être de l'objet d'une tradition
qui remonte très loin le golgotha de
gordon qu'il est beaucoup plus récent
maintenant il semblerait qu'il y ait une
tradition du remonte à l'époque de jésus
pratiquement donc c'est possible que ce
soit quand même cet emplacement là et
personnellement je cours je suis
beaucoup plus partisan de la théorie de
gordon que celle du saint sépulcre
mais alors là nous trouvons autant plus
du livre l'endroit où sont exposés donc
les sept principaux rouleaux de la mer
morte arieh nous a raconté comment on a
découvert les sept premiers rouleaux
dans une des grottes de qumran est le
plus important de ces rouleaux s'élevant
rouleau d'isaïe qui se trouve exposé au
centre de la route ont dû si vous avez
une rotonde où sont exposés les
principaux rouleau le grand rouleau
d'isaïe il était tout à fait lisible
parce que l'air de la mer morte était
tellement sec que la pourriture n'est
pas intervenue c'est notre chance on a
trouvé là des manuscrits bibliques les
plus anciens que l'on connaisse 2000 en
plus ancien que les plus anciens que
l'on connaissait et à quelques variantes
près était en tout point semblable
hanuman jusqu'à nous ce qui montre la
fiabilité de la transmission du texte
biblique alors il ya trois types de
manuscrits on a retrouvé ici vous avez
des manuscrits bibliques dont justement
deux rouleaux dei le grand rouleau
d'isaïe qui est au centre de la retourne
un rouleau qui était en plus mauvais
état et qui étaient incomplets on a
retrouvé un commentaire d'abacus on a
trouvé et ensuite des fragments de tous
les livres bibliques sauf du livre
d'esther il avait ensuite d'aider zekri
apocryphe des apocryphes que l'on
connaissait en grec en particulier et
puis il y avait des écrits qui était
propre à la secte
ce lien sont une secte qui était
marginal véritable une secte au sens
péjoratif du terme des gens qui se
considéraient comme les seuls élus les
seuls sauver et qu'ils se qualifient eux
mêmes ne se qualifie pas des seigneurs
d'es-sénia c'est un nom qui leur est
donné par les autres on n'est d'ailleurs
pas absolument certain à 100% que ces
gens là étaient véritablement des
esséniens eux mêmes savent eux se
disaient les gens de la communauté
c'était des gens qui vivaient ici en
communauté communauté de vie un petit
peu comme moines et qui
se considéraient aussi comme les les
membres de la nouvelle alliance
il avait eu un cofondateur à
ce qu'ils appelaient le maître de
justice qui était un prêtre de la maison
deutz haddock et à partir de l'époque
macchabées n les les prêtres avaient
cessé d'appartenir à la maison de sadok
il était appartenait à la famille des as
monnaie c'était une famille de prêtres
subalterne de clients prince il n'avait
pas le droit la grande prêtrise et
semblerait que le maître de justice le
jour du clip où il a essayé d'offrir de
sacrifices dans le temple il en a été
rejeté par le prêtre il avait su qu'il
appelle le prêtre un pli un pic et qu'il
ne nomme pas à passer de ce moment là il
s'est séparé de duke lutte officielle du
judaïsme il a considéré que le temple
était un endroit soulier et les
étudiants se sont séparés du temps pour
former un temps plus spirituelle composé
de pierres vivantes retrouver cette
idéologie bien sûr dans le nouveau
testament et donc et se sont retirés
sans bêtise au bord de la mer morte est
là donc ils ont ils attendaient le
moment où le véritable top serait
rétabli ou la nouvelle alliance serait
conclu avec le avec la venue du messie
et donc ils avaient une activité
littéraire extrêmement importante
c'était des lettrés les gens qui
utilisaient les écritures des gens qui
se se voulait aussi charismatique
c'était avait des don de prophétie des
dons de guérison et cetera tu es donc
charismatique extrêmement important et
il attendait la réapparition du messie à
la fin des temps
on a prétendu que les esséniens étaient
des pacifistes en fait comme s'il
existait pacifique que ça
simplement il estimait qu' il y avait un
temps pour se révolter contre les
romains et en attendant il fallait
s'entraîner à la guerre et scatologiques
la guerre finale qui aurait vu dans les
derniers temps et pour cela ils ont
écrit un véritable traité d'art
militaire et lorsque la grande révolte
contre les romains éclaté en 66 il est
clair que les esséniens ont vu dans
cette guerre la guerre eschatologie
qu'ils attendaient ils ont participé
tant et si bien que l'aurait
l'établissement a été détruit en 68 par
vespasien quand il a marché sur
jérusalem et quand ils ont compris que
leur sort était scellé les esséniens ont
mis à l'abri leurs biens les plus
précieux et notamment le rouleau dans
les grottes de qumrân si on sait qu'on
va retrouver deux mille ans plus tard
c'est aussi là que on a retrouvé cinq
petits fragments de l'évangile de marc
chapitre 7 de l'évangile de marc il
semble bien que les premiers chrétiens
qui est et à jérusalem est aussi utilisé
les grottes des avions d'airbus pour y
cacher aussi leurs manuscrits c'est très
intéressant parce que là on a un
terminus post co m ça veut dire que
l'inter au delà duquel on peut pas
remonter ses 66 minutes après jésus
christ la destruction de l'établissement
des esséniens par les romains donc on
est certain que l'évangile de marc date
d'avant ces périodes là et non pas de la
vente après la destruction du temple
comme la plupart des spécialistes le
pensent en 1967 avant la guerre des six
jours on avait découvert ici dans une
boîte de chaussures d'un
barak l'avait fui la vieille ville de
jérusalem le plus grand des rouleaux de
la mer morte que vous allez y trouve
exposé là que d'une rouleau du temps et
une vision du nouveau temps peut-être
que doit être une prophétie c'est la
reconstruction du temple et sur la
guerre et scatologique c'est très
intéressant de noter que la description
sévère et scatologiques elle
correspondait exactement à la
description de la guerre des six-jours
da manière dans la guerre des six jours
s'est déroulé
vient alors bienvenue sur le site le sud
est de la ville c'est le cycle
les fouilles sur les plus importantes à
jérusalem puisque ici les archéologues
déjà depuis un siècle et mis presque la
fin du neuvième identifier la capitale
que david créé david j'ai commencé son
règne à hébron après brawn s'est déplacé
francs cette ville j'ai bu site qui va
devenir sa capitale alors on a retrouvé
ici des vestiges de bâtiments
administratifs des vestiges du palais
royal
on a retrouvé des
dessau anciens pour tous les noms des
ministres du dernier roi de judée laura
cd cias donc on sait qu'on est dans le
complexe administratif le complexe royal
les roi de judée qui étaient ici la
grande question avons nous trouvé le
palais du roi david
c'est à gaz et résidentiel chic et on
pense que c'était aussi la vraie vous et
le palais royal le surplomber sur tomber
ce quartier parce que voyez-vous là le
sommet de la colline ne laisse pas
beaucoup de place pour établir une vie
lisse innover obligé d'établir sur des
pentes et la jérusalem de l'époque
dominique ressembler à peu près à ce que
le village touré en face à ces défis
construit sur des terrasses comme ça et
le palais royal donc de dominer tout ça
et vous avez là vu une terrasse à vue
pouvait se promener mais ça vous
explique qu'il ait pu voir en contrebas
ce qui se passait ici sur les toits des
maisons et notamment qu'il ait vu
batsheva qui se baignait et qu'ils
pensaient être à l'abri des regards
indiscrets si ce n'est qu' elle avait
oublié que le roi ait dominé pouvez voir
ce qui se passait ça va être la cause
des malheurs de david et des malheurs de
ce pauvre et en particulier on a trouvé
ici des traces aussi de combattre très
très furieux qui ont eu lieu au moment
de la prise de jérusalem par les
babyloniens et une maison qu'on appelle
la maison brûle et aussi parce qu'on a
trouvé des traces d'une
d'une d'un incendie a été allumé par les
babyloniens moment où la ville est
tombée
on a retrouvé aussi des traces de
deux cuts montré que la population était
pécheresse de savez nous est dit dans la
bible que malgré la réforme de josias le
pape ne s'était pas véritablement
repentis et on a retrouvé ici dans les
cuisines et dans les toilettes qu'on a
fouillé des restes de de nourriture qui
était un héritier non casher et
notamment des poissons sans et cahill et
crustacés des choses comme ça il y avait
aussi pratiquement dans toutes les
maisons des petites statuettes de la
déesse de la fécondité la ds a certaines
qui montre que les habitants de la ville
ne prenait pas garde au haut
commandement de dieu
le mont des oliviers de l'autre côté et
entre nous nous a légué une valley la
vallée du cédron de kidron la vallée de
kidron qu'il avalait qui sépare
jérusalem du mont des oliviers et qui
aussi une variété une barrière
géologique en fait de l'autre côté du
kids run
laroche l'autre côté n'est pas la même
roche que là où on est ici c'est une
frange beaucoup plus friable de l'autre
côté en fait conçu le désert de judée
le village qui en face de nous le
village de silwan mais aujourd'hui un
village arabe s'achever au bout à gauche
et au dessus dans le rocher l'émotion
sur son rocher n'est dans le rouge et or
et d'ouverture c'est des anciennes
tombes c'était en fait la nécropole de
jérusalem c'était des tombes creusées
dans le rocher en face jusqu'au xxème
siècle y'a pas de village dos alors la
fin du xixème siècle il ya quelques
maisons isolées qui sont sur ce set se
plante est alors arrivé en 1882 des
juifs du yémen je règne à deux
communautés juives la communauté
sépharade qui vient de qui est venu
après l'expulsion des juifs d'espagne
qu'il était juif qui date du 16e siècle
qui est du ritz sépharade espagnol est
une communauté ashkénaze qui vient
d'europe de l'est les deux sont très
pauvres les deux vivent de la charité
des communautés desquelles deux
d'origine arrive six yéménites qui
viennent recruter encore plus pauvres
qui peut pas envoyer de soutien
financier et qui c'est qui va les
accepter qui va les incorporer qui va
les prendre avec le cd&v les communautés
locales au japon n'a pas d'argent pour
elle-même et donc personne n'en veut les
logements étant très cher dans la
vieille ville je l aime ces gens vont
s'installer entre gaudi dont sept dans
ce cadre une grève est en fait c'était
le premier village des yéménites ces
caveaux funéraires du mont des oliviers
après ils ont construit des maisons il y
aura un quartier juif en 1936 saison du
circuit à cause des émeutes n'ont plus
pu revenir
donc on a ici une photo de la cité david
actuellement une reconstitution de ce
qu'elle était à l'époque du roi david
donc on est actuellement dans cette dans
cette zone et voilà ce qu'était la ville
à l'époque du roi david une muraille qui
encerclent la ville et au dessus la zone
royal le palais royal la zone la
convention de visites en concert vous
est ici dans la zone du palais royal la
ressource qui donne l'eau à la source du
geer on se trouve ici
maintenant cette source est une
faiblesse de la ville
pourquoi c'est une faiblesse parce que
j'expliquais que l'eau coule vers le bas
donc la source est très basse la logique
aurait voulu qu'on mette la source dans
la ville qu on m
il murray au tour des remparts autour de
la source mais là on a un problème on
perd l'avantagé de la pente c'est un
avantage de mettre une
il murray est sur la pente d'abord
l'ennemi le raid la montée il arrive
essoufflé contraire hoba hoba de la
muraille on lui jette dessus les
cailloux l'eau bouillante et c'est donc
c'est plus et plus et plus davantage de
points de vue défense de m la muraille
plus haut alors pour protéger cette
source on a fait une muraille secondaire
avec une tour de protection c'est déjà à
l'époque anna lindh g14 milan l'époque
d'abraham cas ce système qui protège la
source les envahisseurs donc là sur ses
protégés maintenant il ya un problème
c'est qu'on est aussi sous le mont des
oliviers on domine la ville et donc des
archers son ailier peuvent tirer sur les
gens qui aiment 30 l'eau à la source
donc d'un côté à la source qui est
protégé mais le chemin qui amène vers la
source ce chemin et face aux archers et
on peut tirer surtout les personnes qui
viennent prendre de l'eau et donc on
peut pas prendre de l'eau en cas de
guerre donc j'ai les cananéens et 4000
ans se rendent compte qu'ils ont un
problème et pour régler ce problème et
ils ont construit un tunnel qui amène de
la ville à la source en souterrain pour
pas être en butte aux flèches et la
france qu'on a vu quand on était
amaigrie de l'autre jour auraient fondu
de 100 marches faut arriver deux dans la
ville vers la source en bloquant l'accès
la sauce c'est ce qui fait aussi à
l'époque à l'année n-1 accès souterrain
toutes les comprenait
le ce qui était fait c'est à catherine
on a au burin et au marteau pour faire
un souterrain juste folle en cas de
guerre parce qu'en cas de paix on
amènera avec des mulets ici mais en cas
de guerre il faut l'accès à l'eau
l'importance de l'eau dans la région
quand le roi david arrive il un problème
c'est un jeune roi et u9 nommé roi on
n'a pas encore un état de fait constitue
on se rappelle que les des tribus
seraient elles peuvent pas ce que
j'aurais que les chars de faire des
cananéens dans la plaine
comment est ce qu'on prend une ville
protégée comme ça c'est imprenable il
faut des siens il faut des machines de
siège il faudrait des bélier pour
enfoncer la muraille il faut des
catapultes pour faire baisser la tête au
défenseur et je rappelle ce que dd ce
que disent les cananéens david dusa même
si tous défenseurs sont des unijambistes
et estropiés une passionnante roi pas
dans la ville rappelait que il raille
david duo de la mûre ans il en a aucune
chance d'entrer sa demande
des des moyens militaires des
technologies militaires que tu n'as pas
donc la grande question c'est comment
david a réussi à entrer là je reviens au
livre des chroniques ou d'avis dit celui
qui s'empare de la ville j'en ferai le
chef de mon armée au verset d'après on
voit que joab son neveu a pris la ville
et il va être nommé chef de l'armée de
david maintenant il marqué dans le texte
david a dit celui qui touchera le psy
nord sera chef dans mon âme et ses
sibyllin les commentateurs en europe qui
ont perdu le contact avec nice rennes ne
comprennent pas ce que 7 6 nov certains
disent oui ça rapport avec loca cela
deux ans on voit ce mot cinor deux fois
une fois dans l'histoire de la conquête
de jérusalem et on voit aussi dans un
des psaumes ou david parle de l'eau et
lucie nord non guy sec sur un club on
sait pas de quoi s'agit il de quoi
salaires
les archéologues ont trouvé ici on dit
maintenant c'est ici si tout à l'heure
je l'expliqué claque bazar à fouiller
parce que la bible disait que les
chercher le palais au dessus de la
citadelle donc la bible à et des lettres
que j'existe archéologie qui vient au
secours de la bible il faut bien trouver
ce système d'eau propose les
archéologues
david a eu vent du fait qu' un tunnel
souterrain qui va jusqu'à la source il
dit celui qui arrive à passer par ce
tunnel souterrain et ouvrir les portes
de la ville sera chef de noirs desseins
n'ayant pas les technologies de guerre
pour faire le siège de la ville et y
envoient un commando qui va réussir à
rentrer dans ce tunnel a pour ses lacs
ses rentrées ans tunnel neutraliser les
sentinelles qui garde le tunnel la porte
et ouvrit les portes tout grand d'alarmé
et logique militaire à ça et ça répond à
ces bien ce que le texte ne dit que yo à
balai une fois qu'il a pris 7,6 nord on
hébreu moderne occidental un tuyau donc
c'est un crapaud rigolo mais ça vaut
quoi apparemment je n'avais pas séparés
par ses passes et le show conduit et
ouvert les portes de la ville et c'est
comme ça qu'il avait là plus prendre
cette ville dont il a besoin et du n'y
arrivera pas même si nous sommes tous
être au pied la ville est trop bien
protégées ce que vous écrivez en quelque
chose d'autre à l'époque de l'arrière
arrière petit fils de la vie des classes
quand le roi et qu'a sera attaqué par le
roi d'assyrie sénat chéri ben y'a marqué
qui va détruire l'accès à l'eau
pour éviter que les assyriens depuis sa
rivale hossa qui se rappelle que son
arrière grand père est passé par là il
ne veut pas laisser les assyriens me
faire le même coup donc il détruit
l'accès à la salle au paris s'est mis
lui faut de l'eau dans la ville et pour
pouvoir avoir le drame il va creuser un
tunnel souterrain qui va amener l'eau
vers cette piscine de siloé qui à son
époque la ville a grandi et la muraille
entoure cette piscine donc il va
déplacer l'eau jusque dans la
ville il va détruire cet accès
extérieurs et c'est ça qu'on voit que le
prophète lui dit ne pas toucher que de
livres dès que le texte dit que ce n'est
que ezéchias à bloquer a détruit l'accès
à source de guy phone 7 pour empêcher
les assyriens ce domaine ce tunnel
creusé classe à creuser il existe encore
on l'a trouvé la juste fallu déblayer de
la terre qui s'étaient accumulés et on
peut faire ce parcours de 500 mètres
pieds dans l'eau
ok si on rentre autres jeunes canadiens
à tunnel vieux de 4000 ans
alors là vous êtes devant sa passerelle
on arrive jusqu'à la source du biéreau
que juste l'adulation c'est juste en
dessous et donc les archéologues quand
il commence à déblayer ce tunnel penser
que si on arrivait le tunnel arriver
jusqu'ici édition puiser l'eau dans la
dalle source comment ont jeté des seaux
et ont fusé ça c'était l'explication
archéologiques jusqu'à il ya 20 ans
c'est qu'on découvre que le tueur est
continu
et alors on s'est rendu compte de
l'erreur qu'on a que les archéologues
avaient fait en fait ce qui s'est passé
comment est-ce qu'on a découvert tout ce
système tous ces tunnels charles roven
archéologues anglais qui vient ici au
19e siècle a commencé à chercher la
source il a commencé par la source ils
vendent par la sauce et découvre ce
puits et grimpe dans ce puits men
échelle ighrem dans le puits et
appathurai découvre le tunnel depuis
l'entrée jusqu'au puits et donc il a
toute sa théorie est que tunnel donne
l'accès depuis la ville jusqu'à ce puits
on puise l'eau plus tard claude ont
découvert découvrir qu'une suite est ce
qu'on presse était en plus de terres
fait comprendre qu'ici on pourrait
déblayer et continuer et ce qui s'avère
c'est que en fait le tunnel caréné à 20
vraiment jusqu'au bout jusqu'à la source
est ce qu'on va faire maintenant à
l'époque où le roi ezéchias créé la
dérivation qui prend l'eau de la source
et la détournent vers la piscine de
siloé ils vont découvrir une grotte
naturelle c'est une grosse carte
karstique naturel christine qui étaient
là et façon-là eux vont raccrocher ce
tunnel à au tunnel des cananéens ne
s'était pas une découverte par hasard
soutient n'a pas été creusé par l'homme
c'était une caverne naturel si regardons
ce que vous voyez qu'un bassin
le ce bassin il ya une porte juste en
face de nous qui communique avec la
source en fait l'eau de la source de
gijon alimente un bassin ici
et on pense d'après les archéologues
dépression trouver si on dater cette
cette piscine de l'époque biblique
l'époque du premier temple les 3000 ans
et donc on se rappelle le texte que
nathan le prophète vient chez batsheva
il lui dit hey tu sais david est promis
que ton fils salomon serait son héritier
mais à dounia qui est en train de faire
proclamer roi à la source de m rde elle
est alors batsheva lâché david n 1 et
messieurs roi tu avais promis que mon
fils salomon que notre pi salomon serait
ton héritiers et voilà que adonia au est
en train de renier à ce moment là on
attend tous la même chose et david et
dépêchez vous prenez salomon fait l'an
prochain la mule royal et descendez vers
la source de garonne et là bas vous le
nommez droit est à la source de garonne
ont moins salomon comme roi et le peuple
crie vive le roi selon v le roi salomon
et à devenir se trouve la source d'un
drogué loup est en train de faire son
coup d'état et l'entente la rue mûri
demande qu'est ce qui se passe là bas et
on lui c'est raté salomon bien d'être
problème - comme moi et donc les gens
qui étaient avec ado niasse se débandent
et la révolte a échoué
et c'est intéressant parce que la source
d'un orgue est surtout un peu plus en
contrebas dans la vallée à un kilomètre
et qu'elle glisse si vous avez tout à
l'heure je vais montrer qu'il y avait le
ravin du kids run est là le mont des
oliviers juste en face donc en fait sa
race et encaissé les deux parents sont
très proches donc les causes peut se
révélera très bien et quand je vous
entends que les écoliers canche et les
escaliers l'on sort dehors face au ravin
et on crie bible salomon et entend
comment l'écho résonne de mur en mur et
c'est comme ça que ça porte jusqu'à n
rogallo d'avenir en tant que que salon a
été oint et sa troupe se débandent
mais au touquet et non une entraide une
cas d'une grotte et c on a retrouvé des
grottes mortuaire et les peaux les
archéologues apparemment ils pensent
avoir retrouvé les caveaux de david et
ce que je dis qu'on n'enterre pas dans
la ville de josé inventaire en dehors de
la ville pour des raisons de pureté et
pour des c mais il ya une exception qui
est faite puisqu'on lui dans l'est dans
le livre
des rois que david et ses descendants
sont enterrés dans la cité de david
donc on a longtemps montré le tombeau de
david au mont sion à côté du cénacle
mais ça ne répond pas aux textes en a 2
2 indices dans le texte 1 le fait que
david détenteur d'un stade à vis de jeu
on a retrouvé cette david hâle ici donc
ça correspond pas au point de vue
datation la ville était ici donc c'est
david c'est ici que cherchait il faut
chercher tombe de rabbi très près de la
piscine la piscine selon l'
identification quand même devant nom est
arrivé donc c'est à côté serre que c'est
chacun construit 20 30 mètres de
murailles il faut changer dans les 50
mètres autour de la piscine et se
relaient pour trouver les podiums du roi
david
ça c'est la piste de solaise
n'ayant pas découvertes ont montré
quelque chose d'autre avant qui est en
fait un petit bassin sur le parcours de
l'eau mais ça on comprend maintenant
déjà que cela la piscine qui était la
piscine principale alors à l'époque du
temple événements de cérémonie c'est par
exemple la fête de souccot qu'on vient
de finir on prie pour la pluie pour
l'année on venait ici de le grand prêtre
venez avec une aiguille hier en argent
qu'user de l'eau qu'il offrit en
libations sur l'autel au temple pour
demander la pluie pour l'année qui vient
donc ici se produit à un des principaux
miracle de jésus la guérison d'un
aveugle donné et on va lui céder cet
épisode dans l'évangile de jean chapitre
9 jésus vient pas sans un homme aveugle
de naissance c'est ici plus posé la
question rabhi qui a péché cet homme ses
parents pour qu'ils soient nés aveugles
je lui ai répondu ce n'est pas juste que
ses parents se dépêcher mais c'est afin
que les hommes de dieu sur manifestions
louis il faut que je fasse pendant
qu'ils les jours les oeuvres de celui
qui m'a envoyé un musée en personne ne
peut travailler quand je suis en le
monde je suis la lumière du monde
vraiment dit cela il faille shatter et
fut de la boue avec sa salive puis
applique à cette boue sous les yeux de
la veulent en lui disant vas l'artois au
réservoir de siloé dont qui signifie
envoyée il y à là cela va et se retourna
voyons clair ses voisins ce qui
auparavant elle avait connu comme un
mendiant disait est ce pas celui qui se
tenait à ses écrits mendier vous disais
c'est lui et non mais il lui ressemble
je me disais c'est moi vite donc
continuons ils étaient ouverts répondu
nomme qu'on appelle jésus a fait de la
boue avoir mes yeux et m'a dit vas au
réservoir de siloé et lave toi je suis
allé je me suis lavé j'ai pu voir et me
disent et ils lui dire où est cet homme
répondu je ne sais de mener vers les
pharisiens
or c'est une joue du chat basque juge
avait fait de la boue il est mauvais et
il lui avait ouvert les yeux ce nouveau
les pharisiens lui demandait comment il
avait pu voir il ira piqué de la boue
sur mes yeux je me suis lavé je vois je
crois quelques-uns des pharisiens deal
cet homme ne vient pas de dieu grec
n'observe pas shabbat d'autres dire
comment un homme pécheur petit fait de
tenir at il vu division pas mieux dire
encore à l'aveuglent toi que dj lui sur
su sur ce kit a ouvert les yeux vont 17
un prophète ni juif du flux repas qui
était aveugle et qu'il ait pu voir
jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient fait venir ses
parents il interrogé en disant est ce là
votre fils
celui qui vous ait des aveugles
comment voit-il maintenant c'est pas en
position nous savons que c'est notre
fiche qu'une haine aveugle et comment
ils voient maintenant
qui lui a ouvert les yeux c'est ce que
nous savons et et je le vous même il a
de l'âge il parlera en ce qui le
concerne ses pas l'ont dit cela parce
qu'il craignait les julien carré julien
avait convenu que celui qui
reconnaîtrait jésus pour les messi
serait exclu la synagogue c'est pourquoi
ses parents de lui disait de lui dire il
a de l'âge il est interrogé le lui-même
c'est ici que ce miracle s'est produit
est donc cet homme a été guérie
comme on le sait on le voit si c'était
un vieux qui était utilisé aussi pour
les purifications
servait de migrer dans les grandes fêtes
qu'il n'y avait pas assez de place pour
tout le monde et ça donc on a retrouvé
sa dans des fouilles récentes c'est un
lieu très important pour eux aussi le
l'histoire du christianisme
ce qu'on voit on a commencé ici à
l'entrée de la ville de david on a deux
là on est descendu par le fleuve
souterrain on avait jusqu'à la source du
garonne qui étaient ici on a compté on a
contenu contenu par là la crepuq
souterrain cananéens on est sorti à peu
près dans ce jardin on a continué à la
piscine de siloé qu'on voit ici en
reconstitution de là on a pris le prix
le minibus on est remonté vers le bas
ventre et maintenant ce qu'ils avaient à
l'époque j'ai dit voilà le bassin
reconstituer le bassin de six loups est
monté tout à l'heure avec l'escalier
majestueux qui monte vers le temple donc
c'est un escalier de 16 mètres de large
et plus certains endroits qui monte vers
le temple et c'est intéressant parce que
le texte michelin à michelin nous dit à
quel à partir de quel âge un enfant est
tenu de monter au temple au fait de
pèlerinage nos opinions
l'école des milliers dans l'école de
chaleur en scène quand l'enfant est
assez grand pour donner la main à son à
son père et dessins et de monter au
temple l'école de chamakh disais quand
l'enfant est assez grand pour être sur
les épaules de son père et monte autant
c'est intéressant parce que quand on
viendra vieille ville et qu'on va vers
le temple on descend dans le texte par
qui on y monte maintenant comprends
c'est que le pèlerinage commencé ici par
la purification il fallait monter un
gosse qui était assez fort pour voir
monter assez grand pour monter toute
cette pente
était de tenues de faire le pèlerinage
annuel à jérusalem alors sous cette rue
se trouveront que ce fameux caniveau que
et rod a construit pour évacuer l'eau de
mètres de haut vous avoir deux côtés les
pierres taillées donc s'il a construit
comme ça pour le caniveau en dessous
juste imaginer la magnificience de la
rue et de l'escalier qui était au dessus
on sait qu'ils avaient d une rue avec
beaucoup de marbre avec beaucoup de
belles pierres avec des podiums c'était
le concert live parle de l'époque où
pendant que les gens montent vers vers
le temple on peut haranguer la foule
faire des discours etc c'est un endroit
très vivante jérusalem est on fait donc
le dernier un morceau et on va arriver
alors regardez ça c'est important parce
que ça n'existe plus ça c'est donc là
l'esplanade construit par hérode 500
mètres de long de 350 m de large la plus
grande esplanade sacrées du monde c'est
plus grand que le parthénon c'est plus
grand que rome etc et au centre un
temple énorme 50 mètres de haut
aujourd'hui à le dôme doré à
l'emplacement comment est-ce qu'on
accéder au temple à l'époque deux
entrées principales y avait ici des
escaliers avec deux entrées une porte
triple issime portes doubles qu'on ne
voit pas ici et l'escalier qui monte les
gens montés par le sud appellent les
ports de roul da nous on a professé
school d'acquis à l'époque de jérémy et
la prophétesse qui était assise aux
portes du temple donc on a donné ce nom
à ses portes claquées sur les portes
d'accès au temple il y avait l'accès
principal était là par une très grande
arche un pont un escalier en assurent
une arche qui est rentré par ici
aujourd'hui c'est cette arche est
détruite on verra juste en sortant vers
1 la première pierre de cette arche et
comprendre c'était par là qu est l
entrée principale au temple
c'est pierre szysz et nous rappelle la
destruction de jérusalem par les romains
la rue défoncée ici à côté de nous à
cause de ces pierres qui ont été
projetée du haut de la muraille merci
vous regardez regardez les pierres du
bus du coin du mur il ya des longueurs
des pierres ces pierres font dix mètres
de nom
c'est s'agit des pires deux cents 200
tonnes c'est pierre qui font plus de 10
mètres de long et encore 3 mètres de
profondeur vous le voyez de la largeur
puisque c'est une dans ce sens une dans
l'autre une dans ce sens une dans
l'autre sens on voit la largeur de la
pierre dans les intervalles et donc on
voit de nouveau ce qu'était construit le
roméo un problème avec les juifs les
romains amène une civilisation il amène
la culture is amen
les marchés les routes etc et la plupart
des pays se soumettent dans ce qu'on
appelle la pax romana la paix romaine
c'est le but de romain or il on
apprenait qu'un pays c'est des juifs les
juifs ne se soumettent pas la première
révolte la grande révolte contre titus
la seconde révolte encore plus grande
contre adrien il ya des révoltes
secondaire parce que dans la pax romana
quand un pays est conquis par rome les
romains après le dieu local la joute au
panthéon de rome une cage à temps et en
dieu et en plus ils prennent jupiter car
le capital il n'y a de rome il l'amène
dans le temple local qui est un dieu de
plus et tout le monde se marchent
ensemble chez les juifs ils n'ont rien
amené de prendre du temps qu'il ya pas d
figé dans le temple qui peuvent emmener
à rome et qu'ils amènent jupiter au top
c'est l'émeute donc il ya une
incompatibilité entre la façon juive de
réagir et la façon romaine qui fait que
les jeunes ne souhaitent pas il ya dans
un monde en un an de tailler en pro il
ya des guerres parce qu'on veut prendre
un pays à cause des richesses mais au
niveau 6 au niveau intellectuel au
niveau religieux et pas de problème pour
peu on peut s'entendre alors qu'entre
une menue ions une région noté c'est pas
gagné il ya un gouffre un robot va
combler donc les juifs se rebelle en
corée tout le temps sur fait que les
romains détruites désir d'en finir avec
avec l'état d'israël à jude est de
détruire à tel point que l'empereur
hadrien même effacer le nom est le pays
qui est la judée il va l'appeler la
palestine jérusalem est renommé il ya
qu'obtenir il faut m est passé les non
y'a plus rien de juifs il ya plus de
juifs là la ville et romaine païenne et
s'étonner des juifs
cette pierre était une pierre qui était
en route du mur est en fait cet apparat
pc là une pierre d'angle on voit qu'il
ya un angle c'était le parapet du coin
qui étaient ici et à une inscription sur
cette pierre est marqué le bet attaque
qui al attiyah vers l'endroit où on
sonnait de la salle du chauffard la
sonnerie non je vous rappelle vendredi
soir vous entendu la sonnerie des
alertes qui a sonné pour l'entrée du
shabbat j'ai dit que à l'époque ancienne
yahvé ont sonné du chauffard pour
annoncer que le seul le shabbat allait
rentrer qu'il fallait quitter les champs
fermer les magasins rentrer à la maison
qui est trois sonneries et apparemment
le cohen qui sonnait ces sonneries était
en haut de coin de la muraille 6 face à
la ville est sonné cette sonnerie pour
toute la ville et ça c'était le parapet
pourquoi pas qu'il soit de casse la
figure en bas et ça se rappelle ce qui
se passait ici on annonçait l'entrée du
shabbat à jérusalem il y as 2011 puisque
les gens arrivent par cette rue les gens
ont besoin de changer de l'argent les
gens vous en achetez la boisson
d'acheter de quoi manger d'acheter des
offrandes au temple d'acheter des
souvenirs pour ramener à la maison donc
cette rue c'est la rue commerçante les
marchands du temple c'est pas souvent au
que ça se passe c'est ici que ça se
passe donc dans cette rue là on achète
les offrandes et après on monte au
temple les offrir quand on parle des
marchands du temple c'est dans cette
russie une dernière chose si vous
regardez la pierre au dessus de nous oui
le début de l'arche et cette pierre qui
sort du mur c'est le début de l'arche de
montrésor avec l'escalier qui qui qui a
mené les gens me temple au club
d'escalier dessin les 110 is y arriver
là on est maintenant c'était par là qu
est l entrée en montant de cette arche à
partir de cette arche les archéologues
les architectes ont reconstitué le
l'angle de la la
l'angle largeur et claude rich et
comment boxing d'escalier c'était
l'entrée principale du temple c'est
qu'il y avait ici une entrée et y avait
encore deux entrées au sud une dans le
mur sud on va retrouver aussi mais
c'était puisque la ville est à l'ouest
ses chaussons la ville était habile boxe
c'est la majeure partie des gens
arrivent par la ville et monte par cette
passade escalier vers le temps
on a vu ici ces deux rues principales
qui se croisaient angle droit la rumeur
sud et la rue ouest est remarqué single
la rugueuse et défoncé par le poids des
pierres qui sont tombés par un l'époque
romaine voudrais souligner c'est qu'il
ya une pierre laba queue du cac étaient
tombés sur laquelle il y avait une autre
inscription était au moment peut-être
est écrit semble-t-il au moment où
l'empereur julien di l'apostât celui qui
avait apostasier le christianisme après
constantin de numidia successeur de
constanta avait donc proposé la
reconstruction du temple et les juifs
s'apprêter à recouvrir le temps quand un
tremblement de terre a détruit toutes
les préparatifs qui était fait pour ça
mais il semblerait que quelqu'un est
inscrit un verset du prophète isaïe vous
le verrez votre coeur se réjouira et
vont se reprendre on vu comme l'herbe
c'est ce qu'on appelle des actionnaires
on appelait ça l'optimiste
celui qui avait que croyez vraiment à la
reconstruction du temple et puis
finalement à la pérennité d'israël on
veut toujours y serait d'un son prix
chose que nous réalisons nous même
aujourd'hui ici on est vraiment dans un
endroit très très marquée par l'évangile
c'est là que l'échangeur du temple et ce
tir a remarqué aussi une chose ici
c'était que on a trouvé dans toute cette
région là l'immigré des bains rituels
pourquoi parce que d'autres le moment on
peut dire par exemple on prenait un bain
rituel à la piscine de siloé y avait une
certaine distance par très grande mais
quand même certaines distances à faire
pour venir mon temps et on pouvait sans
s'en rendre compte contracté une
impureté rituel pouviez tombés sur un
cadavre d'un chat crevé et savourant
d'un put alors pouvait être sûr qu'on
entrait dans le temps en état de pureté
rituelle total à l'entrée du temple y
avait dénigré vous en lequel on prenait
une extra purification et vous lisez
dans l'histoire de paul quant au moment
de son arrestation que paul donc appris
cet extra purification ça vous ne
trouverez pas dans vos traductions de la
bible parce que les traits du tueur de
la bible ignore ses coutumes juives là
et par conséquent ils ont traduit
simplement purifier alors que le texte
grec parle vraiment d'une extra
purification
tant qu'ils n'avaient pas le temps pour
pouvait faire le culte au synode en
débat mode dans des hôtels extérieur au
top une fois deux le temps que les gens
bien construit c'est le seul lieu de
culte qui reste au peuple juif on peut
prier partout mais l'endroit est
sacrifiée cet endroit la présence de
dieu sauter c'est au départ l'endroit
ont bien c'est de tout cet endroit du
temple et qui se trouvait jeudi là on
voit maintenant où se trouve le don du
le dôme doré donc ce qui se passe
pendant 2000 ans d'exil on n'a plus le
droit de monter en haut un peu plus pris
en eau pendant certaine époque on ne
peut même pas habiter jérusalem à
l'époque d'adrien j'expliquais la ville
est transformée en ville païenne et
jules sont interdits de séjour à
jérusalem on peut venir un jour par an
le jour de yom de trisha brown jour la
destruction du temple il faut payer un
impôt spécial vendre à venir pleurer
journal m et après faut quitter la ville
donc il ya des fois une présence très
minime à josé mais toujours une présence
au cours des années et dans les quatre
derniers siècles ont pris ici parce que
j'expliquais que le mur fait 500 mètres
de long mais il est couvert par les
maisons avec les maisons soin de saumur
donc on n'a pas accès au mur le seul
endroit où il est accessible cet essai
est donc compris ici dans les quatre
derniers siècles parce que l'endroit le
plus proche du saint des saints de
l'endroit où montent les prières qui est
l'endroit où était large alliance au
sommet de la montagne mépris et ici
c'est être en situation d'exil c'est
être en dehors du temple c'est être à
l'extérieur du mur d'enceinte c'est même
pas un mur du temple ça c'est un mur
d'enceinte un mur de soutènement au
dessus il ya le mur du temple et le
bâtiment du temple donc on est à
l'extérieur
mios doxa occidentale c'est ce que les
chrétiens et non juifs ont appelé
improprement le mur des lamentations
c'était le seul vestige du temple qui
était accessible aux juifs pendant toute
la durée d'exil et ses réseaux laquelle
il venait prier ici devant cet endroit
et les non juifs aient l'impression
qu'ils se lamentait doux nom de mur des
lamentations qu'ils ont donné à cet
endroit
c'était en fait 7,7 ce mur là et le mur
de soutènement de la terrasse sera
quelle a été ta avait été construite par
hérode le grand le sanctuaire pour comme
on dit et aujourd'hui évidemment cet
édifice a été détruit par titus en 70 et
il y a deux
deux édifices qu'on petit trouver une
parce qu'on appelle le dôme du rocher on
peut voir là bas avec la la coupole en
or
qui abrite la rose sacré sur laquelle
riche mais là était ligaturer et sur
laquelle marc besse s'est envolé au ciel
pour y rencontrer les prophètes jésus et
recevoir confirmation de sa mission de
prophètes l'autre édifice qui se trouve
au sud s'appelle la mosquée al aqsa ça
veut dire la mosquée lointaine selon ce
qui est tiré d'un verset du coran où il
est question du voyage nocturne du
prophète béni soit celui qui a emmené
son serviteur de la mosquée la plus
proche jusqu'à la mosquée extérieur la
mosquée la plus lointaine
n'ai pas dit nulle part que cette
mosquée jérusalem mais c'est la
tradition orale qu'on appelle leur a dit
qui a
assimilé la mosquée ult et la mosquée
vue extérieur la mosquée la plus
lointaine avec la boucherie qui se
trouvent ici à jérusalem cette mosquée
est laid
importante et pourtant elle ne l'est pas
suffisamment selon
les musulmans aujourd'hui est en dessous
de l'esplanade que l'on pouvait voir ici
il y a des autres poules qui avait été
construit par hérode le grand qui
servait à différents usages et entre
autres à entreposer les trésors du temps
j'avais aussi les chambres où se
rassemblent et le sanhédrin et les
croisés quand ils sont arrivés ici ont
transformé la mosquée les mosquées en
l'église ils ont appelé l'église du
temple il y avait un ordre de moines
soldats qui résidait à cet endroit gamme
son quartier général à cet endroit
c'était justement les templiers
templiers vient du l'otan parce que ils
savaient leur quartier général dans
précisément ces souterrains qui se
trouve au sud du temps et les les
croisez pas tellement férus ans
nationaux j on
considérait que ses entrepôts étaient
des écuries on appelait ça des écuries
de saint roman samson ça ne sont pas des
écuries mais ça n'a rien à voir avec
salomon mais jusqu'à maintenant importe
ce don est sécurisé salomon qui ne sont
plus accessibles à qui que ce soit en
dehors des musulmans
pour servi de base à la construction
d'une vaste mosquée souterraine a été
construite dans la plus parfaite
illégalité par les musulmans et il
s'était creusée en dépit du bon sens
tant et si bien qu'il y avait un risque
de voir l'espagne à s'écrouler sur de
ceux qui étaient en train de creuser cet
édifice à l'intérieur maintenant des
tonnes de gravats ont été
sortie de cet endroit là et évidemment
il y avait des intérieurs des vestiges
nombreux qui prouvaient l'existence d'un
temple sur cet endroit d'un temple juif
à cet endroit alors pour éviter que l'on
puisse utiliser ses preuves pour
confirmer l'existence de ceux de ce
temple alors les musulmans l'ont détruit
et les des fans des fragments qui était
sorti du temple et et amusé été récupéré
par les archéologues israéliens alors
pour éviter cela aussi on a on passe
maintenant tout ce qui sort de cet
endroit là où picasso est intéressant de
noter que les musulmans sont en train de
détruire un patrimoine inestimable de
l'humanité un patrimoine archéologique
inestimable
et tout cela dans la plus parfaite
indifférence même l'état d'israël par
crainte des réactions musulmans d un
comité national n'ose pas protesté
contre ces fouilles sont illégales et
qui détruisent ce qui est le plus
précieux pour le peuple juif c'est à
dire la preuve de l'existence de ce
temple qui comme on le sait est
maintenant contestée par l'unesco elia
donc qu'une cause une relation de cause
à effet entre séjour illégal qui souffre
est ici et puis la résolution récente de
l'unesco déclarant qu'il n'a jamais eu
le temps plus jouer à cet endroit de
fête puisque les preuves sont
systématiquement détruites alors on peut
affirmer qu' il n'y a pas eu de temps
pour cet endroit madame malheureusement
quand même quelques quelques vestiges
des 3 ou vera vestiges ont échappé et
notamment des sauts et des inscriptions
de ce type là qui vont dans le sens de
l'existence évidemment d'un temple sur
cette esplanade que les journalistes
appellent l'esplanade des mosquées
je vous avais ma fille
et comme le troisième lieu saint de
l'islam
mais le troisième serions c'est à dire
les deux premiers sont beaucoup plus
importants que jérusalem c'est un mec
d'abord et puis médine ensuite je suis
allé ne dépassera jamais la mecque et
médine parce que la mecque et médine sur
les endroits où se déroulait l'essentiel
de la vie du prophète tandis que le
prophète vraisemblablement n'est jamais
venu à jérusalem est là son soi-disant
voyage nocturne a été ponctuel de toute
manière donc je voudrais me sera
toujours en troisième rang après la
mecque et médine dans la tradition
musulmane
de fait sur le rocher sur le rocher qui
est vérité vraisemblablement
l'emplacement du lieu très sain on
distingue deux ans actualité qui sont
artificielles une par laquelle passent
et le mur sud
notre souci
du jeu très ça et puis dû voter est à
dire du côté du mont des oliviers il y à
une facture hésiter du rocher qui est
taillée exactement dimension de lâches
et
les afflux hologue qui ont découvert
cela pense que c'était l'endroit où
était déposé les audiences étaient un
petit peu plus large ce qui devait y
avoir aussi vraisemblablement un exemple
un exemplaire de la torah qui étaient
déployés pour les musulmans c'est
l'entrée du pru dupuis de du séjour des
morts et quand viendra le dernier jour
l'ange gabriel se tiendra sur cette
pierre et sonnerat de la trompette il
donnera le signal de la résurrection des
morts et les morses sortiront par cet
endroit là
en hébreu a bercé l'ami d'un côté la
ville de la mise qui fait que j'ai
expliqué que les arbres gens à regarder
les noms des villages et des villes
juives des fois on défend un petit peu
là ils ont traduit il appelle en arabe
il appelle la bile de ré brawn el khalil
lamy la miss est abraham l'ami de dieu
rêveront gossip dire le lien leur a
bercé rejoindre de choses d'après la
tradition juive vient ici quatre couples
qui sont enterrés 300 marqué dans la
torah c'est abraham et sarah isaac et
rifka rebecca et jacob et les a donc la
ville la ville de 4 la ville du lien
entre ce monde c'est le monde d'après et
donc à bram insiste énormément pour
acheter ce champ iphone va l'acheter et
vaillante et ré sarah plus tard il sera
enterré lui-même et donc au début quand
efron dans un premier temps est froid
dit je te donne prend le terrain ah ben
non je veux l'acheter et alors le prix
la montée mais au début la réponse à la
réaction des fraudes la première
élection était que le prince de dieu
parmi nous le meilleur de nos tombeaux
est à toi est vrai nom je veux attaques
de vente je veux un acte d'achat je veux
l'acheter et donc à bram insiste
énormément pour acheter ce champ iphone
va l'acheter et vaillante et ré sarah
plus tard il sera enterré lui-même look
c'est une caverne dans un champ
apparemment une caverne double marqué
l'un des brevets du redoux une caverne
double qu'à berne depuis notre caverne
mais plus tard hérode va construire le
site on peut regarder le bâtiment on
voit au moins dans la partie basse
quelque chose qu'il aura pleinement le
mur à jérusalem c'était très rock c'est
peut-être pas érodé des disques ventilés
en tout cas la construction c'est le
style c'est le style de l'époque ces
grands battus ces grandes pierres avec
en partie supérieure des pilastres des
défauts se défausse colonne des colonnes
comme des clones dans la pierre c'est
comme ça qu'ils étaient aussi le mur à
jérusalem mais je rappelle que hier que
la partie supérieure du mur était
détruite par les romains donc ces
colonnes c'est pilastres entiers
détruits et aujourd'hui au mur il nous
reste que la partie inférieure je dis
qu'aujourd'hui nous reste quinze mètres
sur le 40 m que faisait le mur à
l'époque et reviennent donc on a ce
bâtiment est assez imposant et cela
sinon on va passer plusieurs stades donc
à l'époque c'était
un lieux de sépultures juives ça
deviendra à l'époque des croisades une
église envoie le mur qui dépasse frais
de nous deux côtés est parti de l'église
des croisés et à l'époque où les
musulmans vont revenir ils vont acheter
deux minarets et transformer le bâtiment
en mosquée donc c'est un bâtiment qui a
passé par le stade juifs le fait
chrétien le stade musulmans et pendant
les siècles de domination musulmane les
juifs n'ont pas accès au bâtiment pas
rentrer dedans et pendant plusieurs
siècles ont pris à côté du mur en bas il
ya des nids un escalier le long du mur
et on peut monter jusqu'à la septième
marche après pas droit de continuer on
s'habitue appris à septième marche il ya
aussi une tradition juive qui dit que
c'est là que puisqu'il s'agit d'une
caverne sur laquelle est conçu le
bâtiment que la caverne est juste dans
le coin donc on est à 100 km h en fait
on est en droit le plus proche possible
des patriarches à la guerre des six
jours quand il serait leur revient et
ben on la joue un général en chef fait
détruire les marches en lisant ces
marches un souvenir de l'exil à
souvenirs de l'opprobre et je lui fais
pas faire entrer maintenant on peut
prier l'intérieur il fait détruire les
marches
tombeau ce qu'on voit à gauche c'est pas
un ton
c'est un monument dire qu'en bas bien
tombe au tombeau des patriarches des
cavernes en dessous donc ce qu'on a ce
nivau ici c'est juste des monuments pour
dire il ya une tombe quelque part là en
dessous je me suis arrêtée juste un
instant pour ce tableau c'est un tableau
d'un peintre qui habiterait dronne
bahonar chauny lapin trois paysages à
droite nouvelle que rue de la harpe et
là où on est maintenant je vais le
bâtiment avec les dans le panneau de
droite avec les deux minarets il faut y
voir là la gauche au préfet le temple
d'hérode donc jérusalem le temple au
chaud en prenant et à gauche on voit le
tombeau de joseph à sichem est au dessus
il ya ce texte j'ai trois endroits ne
peut pas être contestés par les nations
du monde en disant israël vous avez volé
c'est le coût trop bon de marquer là le
temple à jérusalem est le tombeau de
joseph qui sont ces trois endroits qui
ont été achetés donc ici cette salle est
dédiée à branislav à abraham à droite
sahara à gauche celle ci devant nous à
jacob et les à
ces salles avec ses monuments c'est pas
dans ce mouvement qui sont intéressés
pas dans ces salles c'est juste pour
donner cette idée que le patriarche
là on est dans la cour de ce qu est l
église à l'époque des croisades la nef
principale en est le mur ici c'est le
mur ou qu'on a vu de l'extérieur donc
ils s'étaient laquelle à l'église
construite par les croisés et
retransformé après par les musulmans en
mosquée
cependant la présence musulmane et juive
n'ont pas leurs prix si on peut prier
que dehors sur les escaliers qui sont à
l'extérieur la provence nouveau bâtiment
en 67 on revient ici la guerre des six
jours et on retrouve le lieu à la prière
juive musulmane chrétienne tout beaucoup
de monde peut rentrer
chose d'intéressant à se rappeler la
ville de hébron a été prise en 67 a tiré
une salve de mitraillettes en l'air
l'aumônier général de l'armée le raf
gorée monte au mont sinaï avec un
chauffard est un rouleau de la torah
dans les bras sur les du chauffard on
est revenu au mont sinaï mais quand ils
m ont signalé une annonce que l'armée
sur le point d'entrer à jérusalem alors
il prend un hélicoptère il fonce à
jérusalem est le premier à entrer avec
les troupes de
les paras qui rentre dans la vieille
ville et ben prière et faire une
bénédiction de chéri un odieux remercie
dieu qui nous a ramené à jérusalem est
qui nous a permis de vivre ce jour c'est
devenu un des emblèmes de la bataille de
jérusalem mais il en train de fêter
jérusalem qu'on lui annonce que l'armée
vient de libérer tombeau de rachel alors
ils foncent à bethléem et il coupe la
coupe la chaîne qui veut bloquer la
porte et ils ouvrent irait ouvre le
tombeau de rachel au culte juif puisque
nouveau pendant les 19 années
d'occupation jordanienne aucun juif
n'avait pu prier au tombeau de rachel et
on le dit que l'armée campent déjà
devant hébron marie france agissent a
dit que son chauffeur il va est bon et
alors ils arrivent au petit matin est
bon il ya une petite erreur l'armée
était devant et bompas dans hébron et
lui ait mal compris il fonce dans la
ville et donc ils foncent un général et
son chauffeur sont tout seuls à fond son
avis il se rend compte que les personnes
dans les rues sur toutes les fenêtres et
drapeau blanc rédigé tire une salle de
mitraillettes en l'air pour qu'il sache
qu'on est là et quand ils arrivent ici
autour de la marque et là il rencontre
le maire de hébron qui lui offre les
clés la reddition de la ville de réponse
est donc juste après le l'aumônier
général rapidement de rennes ouvre le
site de toma lun mar bella à la prière
va venir le ministre de la défense qui
diront ça aux musulmans dit non c'est à
cette année on va ouvrir tout le monde
tourne tout trier et ça va être pendant
plusieurs années pendant des années ça
va être le lieu de prières de tout le
monde juif musulman des foyers une
séparation deux jours de fête mais en
gros le site est entièrement ouvert à
tout le monde juste à hautmont des
accords d'oslo il ya le médecin de qatar
bas
de l'autre la ville juive qui est là qui
vient le matin aux aurores prière
musulman qui ouvrent le feu sur les
musulmans pendant la prière en tout cas
ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'après le
gaumont israélien a d'abord fermé
pendant plusieurs mois l'accès au site
et après a séparé en deux parties la
partie juive la partie musulmane et a
pas de passage entre les deux où là
c'est deux petites salles abraham et ça
va jacques aubé la sondeuse petite salle
au fond à droite est une très très
grande mosquée et donc la basse classe
la salle brisach et de rebecca et à dix
jours par an où tout le site est ouvert
aux juifs uniquement du jour de fête et
par souci de ces procédés aussi du jour
où ses vêtements musulmans les justes ne
peuvent pas rentrer et d'un homme
maintenant ce qui est intéressant c'est
que quand on arrive aux 67 voudrait bien
vont maintenant rentrer dans cette cette
caverne on peut pas y avoir accès quand
les musulmans étaient là maintenant on
veut y aller alors le bonus de défense
167 moshe dayan le borgne et est
archéologue il ya dans la salle de isaac
et rebecca il ya un entraîneur puis est
en dessous il ya des il ya des démarches
mais le cui est très étroit et peut pas
passer alors il envoie là-bas la fille
d'un de ses officiers mistral qui on en
corde elle descend a pris un couloir et
après c'est bloqué par un gros rocher et
elle ne peut plus passer et elle revient
au petit jour parce qu'il ya là bas il
ya une vingtaine d'années les gens les
juifs de hébron blessé par ce qui se
passe et donc c'était de rentrer voir ce
qu'il ya pendant la fête le mois qui
précède rocher shana le début de l'année
on fait des prières pendant la nuit des
prières de repentir et dans les
coulisses fait rien on fait ça en
chantant ça se chante ans et très
bruyants alors on dit de venir de
chanter très fort revient avec un
marteau piqueur et on élargit depuis
pour passer on fait sauter le rocher qui
bloquaient le passage et il arrivait une
caverne il en a une grotte avec beaucoup
d'eau cement c'est logique parce qu'à
cause du lieu saint et des gens qui
voulait être enterré à côté de cette
grotte conduit un autre notre escaliers
dans une deuxième groupe j'ai dit à
l'heure qu'il s'agit de deux gros dessus
de la pesée d'amara tamar pelles à la
laque à berne double et donc ils aiment
la deuxième il ya de nous voir un rocher
qui va la porte qui vous faire sauter
mais à ce moment-là leurs amis et leur
dit il faut sortir parce que le jour je
commence à poindre et les musulmans vont
venir pour la prière donc ils plient
leur matériel en espérant revenir le
lendemain le problème est que les
musulmans se rencontrent toutes appelées
mal mis sous le tapis et voient ce qui a
été fait de faire le trou et il appelle
la police et la police a mis du béton
coulé du béton et on peut plus passer
pour
pour elle donc on sait toujours pas ce
qui se passe là bas
alors des rhodes a construit un palais
avec un palais en cercle avec des tours
sur le côté avec une grande tour ça
c'est un palais avec des thermes romains
donc des bains avec des salles d'apparat
il s'est construit un mausolée dans la
pente pour être sa tombe le jour où il
décède il a préparé une allée pour être
là les du défilé du cortège funéraire il
a préparé un théâtre ça c'est l'hérault
du héros dion après ce palais
ce tombeau toit était recouvert de terre
et a fait cette montagne artificielle
aujourd'hui on va juste à fleurs le
sommet de cette tour et il a créé une
montagne tout ça c'est de la terre qui
étaient amenées pour créer une montagne
pour que son tombeau soit apparent
paysage est qu'on est sur une hauteur
beaucoup plus élevé que tout ce qui
tourne nous s'est construit montagne
artificielle pour être intérieur la
dette un petit peu mégalo sa mégalomanie
n'avait d'égal que sa schizophrénie et
son sa part à l'inria et donc il a ce
n'est pas mal de monde dans son
entourage il assassine elle la femme sa
femme préférée myriam une princesse à ce
modèle il assassiné par peur qu'elle
complotent contre lui et après ils
couraient comme un fou noir palais
myriam myriam et l'a fait en bout et
dans du miel pour conserver son teint et
sa beauté il a fait tuer son beau frère
parce que son beau myriam fait nommer
son beau-frère grand prêtre et il avait
vu que le sombre furent beaux son
beau-frère et être élu par le peuple il
y avait un concurrent il a fait éliminer
son beau frère il a élu les deux de ses
fils qu'il soupçonnait de comploter
contre lui donc il y avait aucune
garantie est dans l'entourage proche de
hérode tu veux regarder au fond là bas
vous voyez il ya un bassin avec jean
allées couvertes juste autour c'est une
piscine dans une cuisine natation mais
là il a fait encore mieux c'est très
grand c'est un bassin aux pénos mon âge
on pouvait faire de la barque sur le
bassin et avec une île artificielle ou
au milieu pour se reposer notre
motivation au centre d'une île
artificielle
je répète on les nomme désert
héros n'a jamais été dérangé par la part
le paysage ici c'est plat donc il fait
il faut construire montagne on est dans
le désert donc il fait des piscines à
jérusalem il ya une montagne qui est
trop petite salle au temple alors il
agrandi fait l'esplanade du temple
cesare il ya une côte droite alors il
fait un port artificiel
la topographie naturelle ne dérange pas
lui il dépasse et ils construisent qu'il
en tête dans tous les palais d'hérode on
trouve une piscine et le nombre de gens
qui se sont noyés dans les piscines des
rois des 501 ferrand une des façons de
se débarrasser d'un
de quelqu'un de gênante et de l'inviter
à la piscine et de prendre deux esclaves
kali tuna de la tête sous l'eau le temps
qu'il faut et après deux passes et une
notice nécrologique dans lequel on
déplore l'accident la mort accidentelle
d'un tel mort noyé dans la piscine donc
ça savait aussi aux exécutions de deron
toutes ces piscines n'est pas très aimé
par par la foule par le peuple pour ça
qu'il a essayé de remplir le temps de
reconstruire le temple en fait le
deuxième temple hill à free un troisième
il a carrément tout fait à neuf est
beaucoup plus grand dans le but de se
faire aimer ça n'a pas beaucoup servi
il était très sanguinaire est très dure
avec le peuple mais c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça qu'il était roi nommé par les
romains parce que l'époque des romains
qui sont les patrons et les romains m la
cruauté aime les gens sanguinaire 10e
les jeux de tirs qu'ils aiment les
et les combats de gladiateurs et donc
quelqu'un du gabarit de
d'hérode était fait pour leur plaire et
c'est pour ça que l'on nommé roi de
judée il avait même compris que le jeu
ou humour et ce sera un jour de fête et
pour éviter que ce débordement de joie
le jour de sa mort il avait fait il
avait fait arrêter 400 notable il a dit
à son fils arceus le jour où je meurs tu
les exécute comme ça les juifs leur ont
peut-être pas pour moi mais le jour où
mouvementée ray les juges sont en pleurs
y aura 400 des notables le josem qui
seront mis à mort art qu'elle a lu ce
qui leur succèdent n'a pas le gabarit il
a la stature de son père etc constituent
fait ça c'est fini tu auras fini de
gagner avant même doit recommencer parce
que le peuple ne pardonnera pas et tu
n'auras jamais jamais 1,7 ont trôné sur
ce meurtre et donc leur qualif n'a pas
exécuté cette dernière recommandation
d'hérode n'a pas n'a pas exécuté les 400
notable par contre ils étaient 1 voix
faible donc ça ne correspond pas à ce
que les romains chercher et après dix
ans de pouvoir il sera déporté par les
romains en gaule
c'est loin pour la plage la judée et
finira près de vienne un jour le
lyonnais ce débat en dessous de la
france quelque part mais arcalis était
enterré en france
quand dans le nouveau testament on a
l'impression qu'un seul et rose joue le
même parce qu'il porte sous tous le nom
des rôles ils sont tous appelés redon
nouveau testament en fait il ya quatre
votes différents une quatre générations
des modes première génération ces
derniers récupèrent ces règlements selon
siddiq sp6 sujet construire au john et
qu'en même temps c'est lui qui nomme le
nouveau testament est l'assassin des
enfants bethléem
ensuite il décède et son royaume est
partagé entre plusieurs de ses fils à
arqués la hausse revient à jude et à
hérode antipas ce la galilée et la paix
réjouit la transjordanie juive et puis à
philippe revient tout ce qui est de
l'autre côté donc du jourdain le golan
ce qu'on appelle être à fond ne serait
appelé à cette époque là
à la hausse comme cette erreur sera
rapidement déposée et la judée deviendra
sera directement administrée par rome
par un gouverneur romain d'où le fait
que moment où jésus va être crucifié la
judée directement administrée par sommes
pas revenir au mans et qui se nomme
pilates
donc un nouveau testament il est
question très peu dark et la hausse si
ce n'est pour dire qu'après la mort
d'hérode joseph revient d'egypte parce
qu'il apprend que héros des morts mais
il craque et la hausse et il va pas
s'installer à bethléem il va aller
s'installer à nazareth parce qu'on pense
qu'il est plus longuement parlé de deux
secondes à deux générations d'hérode
hérode antipas ce le leroy tétrarque de
galilée de père est celui là est
l'assassin de jean baptiste et celui
devant lequel jésus a comparu aussi à
son procès
troisième génération d'hérode hérode
antipas l'erreur d'agrippa ce premier
celui dont il est question dans le jeu
au début du livre des actes il est celui
qui a mis à mort jacques et qui va
mourir dans une
manifestation grandiose à césarée
d'après luc pour s'être proclamé
lui-même d'essence divine
qui va tomber brusquement mort dit l'udc
entend vaisselle etc la ronger de verre
à quoi ça correspond exactement sur le
plan musical difficile de dire en tout
cas fallu joseph nous confirme cette
mort brutale des radars gripas premier
qui donc va mode va décéder à ses arrêts
alors que il a il était l'ami de
l'empereur claude et il avait donc été
rétablie roi sur tout l'est surtout les
domaines de son grand-père érode les
robes de grands ils avaient donc le le
royaume de judée a été reconstituée pour
les robes pour eux il ne s'agit pas ce
qui va réduire tout et pour tout quatre
ans peuvent y va décéder dans des
positions nous avons évoqué tout à
l'heure et puis bien 4e et ron et roda
gripas deux tentes les douze questions
en vivres des actes qui est celui devant
lequel
paul a comparu à la faim de vivre des
actes donc pas à expliquer son cas
devant à gré à gré à gré passent deux
ouverts les quatre générations d'hérode
l'arrière-grand-père de grands le
grand-père hérode antipas ce le fils et
roda gripas premier et puis le petit
fils et roda gripas 2